[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: ReCAPTCHA has over a
decade of experience defending
the internet, and
reCaPTCHA Enterprise
builds on that experience to
provide frictionless security
for your business.
ReCAPTCHA Enterprise is built
on the existing reCAPTCHA API
and offers granular
insight and detection,
allowing you to
understand and tune
the protection you
need for your website.
Let's take a look at what makes
reCAPTCHA Enterprise different.
There are three primary
advantages to note here.
First, reCAPTCHA Enterprise
provides a frictionless user
experience, leveraging advanced
risk analysis techniques that
distinguish between
humans and bots
without requiring customers
to complete a challenge.
Second, reCAPTCHA Enterprise
offers enhanced detection
with granular scores, reason
codes for risky events,
mobile app SDKs, password
breach and leak detection,
multifactor authentication,
and the ability
to tune your own
site-specific model.
And finally,
reCAPTCHA Enterprise
provides the support, like the
SLAs and SLOs, that you expect
from a Google Cloud product.
So if you expect a lot from your
reCAPTCHA integration in usage
or in support, or if you want
to detect automated attacks
or threats against
your website that
may originate from human
actors, mobile emulators, or bot
software, then reCAPTCHA
Enterprise is right for you.
For existing reCAPTCHA
v2 and v3 users,
we've made it a priority
to make migration simple--
so simple, in fact, that it
should only take two minutes.
First, navigate to your project
in the Google Cloud console.
You'll need to enable the
reCAPTCHA Enterprise API.
While you're here, be sure
to note your project ID.
Second, navigate to
google.com/reCAPTCHA/admin
to find your existing
reCAPTCHA site key.
You can find your existing
v2 and v3 site keys
under Settings.
Click the cog icon to
open the Settings view,
and then expand the section
labeled reCAPTCHA keys.
Copy the site key.
To perform the migration,
you can use Cloud Shell.
Note that your account will need
to be either a project owner
or have the reCAPTCHA
Enterprise admin IAM role.
A major benefit of
using Cloud Shell
is that all authentication
is handled automatically,
as the Cloud Shell
instance is already
tied to your user account
and its existing credentials.
However, if this
is the first time
you run a command that
requires credentials,
you will need to authorize
Cloud Shell first.
To perform the key
migration, you only
need a single command--
run gcloud alpha
recaptcha keys migrate.
And specify the v2 or
v3 reCAPTCHA site key
you wish to migrate and
the project ID of the cloud
project where you enabled
the reCAPTCHA Enterprise
API earlier.
You should see a
confirmation that your key
has been successfully migrated.
Back in the Cloud console,
we can see our migrated key
under Security--
reCAPTCHA Enterprise.
Here, we can see analytics and
manage the key moving forward.
And that is how you can easily
migrate your existing reCAPTCHA
v2 and v3 site keys to
reCAPTCHA Enterprise for truly
frictionless security.
To learn more about
reCAPTCHA Enterprise,
go to cloud.google.com/recaptcha
enterprise.
[MUSIC PLAYING]